what's the
[Music]
move we lead our boys
through so you're right
me my girl wor riding to is hard to
[Music]
find not if you know where to look I'll
miss you every
second major Egan you were the first
pilot assigned of the 100s me and B clev
you are in charge of 35 planes and 350
air
crewmen don't you die on me before I get
over
there something big is brewing the E
will be sending up the largest airada
ever assembled in the history of mankind
straight into Hitler's
territory been in complete and total air
superiority that's the
mission what you might be the last
pretty face I ever
[Music]
see what's the
move we lead our po
Throne all than we
do day in day out does something to a
guy doesn't it
we here to fight the monsters the things
these people are capable of they got to
coming trust
me Lord guard and guide The Men Who fly
through the great spaces off the sky are
we tusy men or what sir yes sir be with
them traversing the air in darkening
storms or Sunshine fair I think we may
be done we are going to sit here and
take it we're going to stick with our
mission as long as we can
fly we won't go without a
[Music]
fight